[Music]
foreign
hey guys so right now we are in a closed
shop in Central London and what we're
going to be doing is looking for the
perfect outfit for Pearl to snare her
ideal man do you think
it's too short yeah
I'm trying to be more like a I'm being
sorry yeah
you've got to accentuate your uh key
your key assets are having you so what's
your what's your favorite parts of your
Pursuit I feel like I have no sleds
exactly exactly so that's that's the key
thing I mean that's nice because it's
it's nice it's super Slinky it's quite
short it's got the nice Diamante yeah
[Music]
yeah personally I quite like animal
prints I think it's quite sexy I'm not
sure about this though the shape of this
it seems a bit odd that could be bad no
I just whenever I look at clothes from
Pearl I think about her hair color and
her skin color and that's why I'm like
oh maybe what about this thing here this
xyq for you I don't know there you go
there you go they're coming off the
shirt I'm wearing yeah yeah definitely
yeah see
I could be for the right man though
that's like when women find it my God
after they find their man he happens to
be the Christian yeah it's like oh my
god I've been Jewish the whole time
[Laughter]
[Music]
this one's too small it's too big we'll
see so we're going home I think we did
good I personally don't think Troy will
throw out throw out all of my outfits I
reckon it's going to be a good 85 yeah
Gordon Ramsay a fashion I think your
closet's gonna get annihilated as it
rightfully should as I rightfully should
so that long line not what I expected uh
we might starve to death Adam preached
Aben preach I love Advent speech I've
been watching them for years I've been
wanting them to react to my stuff for so
long and I just got notified they did a
hit piece on me
[Music]
I haven't watched it
I'm nervous I'm nervous if you cry
that's perfect you're in your feminine
so it's okay oh okay okay
um read in the comments the number one I
think she's joking around to be honest a
lot of people shouldn't have the right
to vote but that's a different
conversation because this is what he did
this is what he did okay I said this is
what I said feminist want equal and if
you want equality men in the U.S anyways
are drafted so you get into Selective
Service when you turn 18 and so if
there's a time of War you get drafted I
think if women want to vote you should
equally draft us that's not equality but
we don't want to have that conversation
It's like because they want all the
benefits of voting without the
consequence of getting drafted um and
personally I would not want to be
drafted but see this is why I was
hesitant to put that on camera because I
was like I know how they're gonna take
it I feel like I've learned a lot
apparently if I want results in life I
have to start talking to boys being sexy
helps and dating yeah and wife me up if
you're if you're in the London area oh
you need to want four kids or more well
I'll settle for four
okay guys we're back at the apartment
and we're gonna try on the outfits today
how do you think this is gonna go I
think it's gonna go well I feel like you
really need the help and I like Troy's
honest feedback the man is arguably the
most fashionable man in the manosphere
yeah the other male content creators
that can be upset but my answer to that
would just be to dress better I'm sorry
I think it's gonna be really exciting
we've got some decent outfits for you
here Paul so we're going to see a
transformation occurring I'm sorry I'm
going to show you some of my old outfits
too so you can you can beat up you could
say if I could keep them or get rid of
them I think that the outfits that
Paul's chosen today we're going to see a
Mort's Improvement
um it's gonna be interesting to see some
of her old outfits she's talked about
being a bit of a tomboy being a bit you
know one of the guys so I think we're
gonna see an upturn in the femininity
with something outfits we've chosen
today so I'm looking forward to it I
think it's gonna go really well I love
Pearl she is such a good person and I
just don't think that she deserves to
continue dressing the way that she
dresses very kind-hearted but I I can't
take it anymore the woman is past 600
000 subscribers on YouTube it is time
for an upgrade so that way we can see
the glamor of one million subs and and
maybe you shouldn't get a man out of it
too this is one of my old outfits um
this was my mother's dress and it looks
like it
what you don't like it it it's uh it's
it's pretty but I don't think it's
showing the figure to the to the best
possible
okay what do you think well the purpose
of that
family function but we are not there yet
so the dress is not useful that's post
stuff you get a man and then get this
dress yes for the family for the family
it depends on the Family's credit score
you get a man and then 40 years later
you go
we have one in the UK frumpy it looks a
little bit frumpy
um she said it was her mum's dress it
looked a little bit some like something
someone's Mum would wear
um we need to see a little bit more Edge
we need to see a little bit more style I
just don't like it there's no way to
describe it it's a good spring dress for
Easter Service and that's about it I
like Lumberjacks so I like men who are
probably like you know five eight five
Ten kind of bulky stuff right yeah uh
preferred understood if it's not
happening yeah you know at a minimum
goatee so actually if it wasn't for the
CD passed you might go for Sterling
Cooper a bit more because he's you know
quite stocky yeah not still you know
he's got he's quite he's quite built
yeah I mean I think objectively as a
married woman I think I could say
Sterling happens to be a handsome man
you know objectively there you go there
you go what about the tights are you
feeling the tights am I feeling the
tapes oh man oh man um actually there's
something I'm so I'm so sorry there's
something about Andrew Tate's head shape
and eyebrows back so I could do it but
I'm sure that I'm not on his Hit List in
terms of like women I'm sure that man
wants nothing to do with me a short
Puerto Rican but no not him for me I
just have a specific kind of guy that I
think I I look for but I also think that
that standard is set by my husband but
that's how you know it's a good
hypergamous choice is when you judge
every other man yeah but the man that
you're with you're like ah something's
off like well that means you've hit the
jackpot doesn't it hypergamy wise this
we got a Zara
now this has got it going on a bit more
hasn't it okay nice pattern is it too
short I was a little nervous it was too
short no the length is good man the
length is good he's showcasing your your
legs which he said is one of your you
know like top attributes I think it's
quite it's got a certain it's got a kind
of 70s vibe to it hasn't it yeah yeah I
think so I like the length and then if
you're if you're worried about it
being perfect for a day day I think even
nighttime it depends on like the shoes
Okay okay so I could go on a date on
this side what do we read at one to ten
I think it's coming in at about a 7.5
7.5 this is also my mother's dress well
actually
I think that one's a bit better I
actually think that's a bit better don't
you worry I do because it's fit to your
figure but I mean we just have to give
your mom her clothes back
um what do you have to say to Jennifer
she's gonna watch this video Jennifer
why did you give Pearl your clothes you
didn't have to you didn't have to how
many of her clothes does he have how
many of your clothes does she have she
seems to have the entire wardrobe here
oh but that is actually I think that's
actually pretty nice but for me to be
honest for a day it's probably a little
bit too I'd just go for something a
little bit more exciting a little bit
more flirty a little more flirty yeah
maybe I go my problem is I go to dance
dress like business yeah yeah that's a
problem that's probably the oh okay I
should show a little bit of skin on Dave
show a little bit of skin okay you have
a great class yeah okay okay
is my next outfit all right okay okay
okay
your high value man hunting it looks
like how about what do we rate this one
to ten oh it's got to be an eight an
eight maybe maybe even an 8.5 I mean
that is Slinky it's sexy it's like
evening wear perfect for a night out on
the town I'll do the Full Throttle play
yeah I like it I like it I'd like to see
what kind of purse you pair with it and
what kind of shoes
let's not talk about it okay
well I know what I'm getting her for
Christmas I'm gonna get her a purse
how important do you think clothing the
guys wear is for women I guess it varies
no I now that I know a lot more about
the red pill and I guess I'm older you
know and the manosphere on 27 so
basically my breast milk is powder but
fashion matters a lot like there were
guys when I was younger that I would
have liked to have dated them but they
didn't take care of their appearance at
all and you don't want to be embarrassed
out in public with the man that you're
with yeah and I actually think that men
need to ditch the graphic tees they're
appropriate in some circumstances you
know like a graphic tee and some
Lululemon shorts and you're on the way
to the gym I think that's fine but it
gets to a point a man is like 40 50 the
Star Wars shirt I'm like I just I don't
know how I feel about that but I think
is definitely important and it can take
a guide to the next level
yeah I think that's right actually so
once I'm
um I told a girl who worked in a big
department store here fancy department
store and I was wearing this coat and at
the time it was really well fitted Co he
had this big fur collar thing and um I
walked in and I saw her we got eye
contact we got talking I got a phone
number Etc anyway after the event I said
to her so what was it about me you know
what did you like about me when I first
came in and she said well I really love
that that code you were wearing and it
wasn't that the coat itself she was like
it just looked like it looked like a
military it looked like super cool you
know and she said I wanted to get to
know you and it wasn't like the coat
itself obviously was the the thing that
sealed the entire deal but it certainly
helped well in America a lot of people
are very frumpy and so if you just dress
well it's gonna set you like light years
ahead and I think women have a natural
instinct into being more attracted to a
man who's well dressed because I think
it screams you know like resources like
hypergamy and a lot of guys in a suit if
it's age appropriate then they're gonna
be more attractive than a man who's in
that same age group and if he's just in
you know like shorts and a shirt oh oh
interesting
you see I got in it right so basically
right on one level I quite like that
because it's sort of it looks like 70s
wallpaper
but on another level for what we talk
about here I I don't I wouldn't set up
on a date wearing that I wouldn't I
shouldn't go on a date wearing this no
no I mean here's the thing I want so
desperately not to like that dress but
somehow it really works with your figure
but I don't think that it's I would wear
it you know on a dress I think it
depends on the nature of the day like
what kind of date are we talking about
let's say let's say going to the
hawkstone
what is that it's like uh how would you
describe the hawkstone it's like a
it's like a boss and a uh like Lounge
kind of place yeah okay this is why I'm
conflicted wear it for your girlfriends
don't wear it for your man different
different that's what I think that's
mine I think it looks quite cool I think
it looks quite cool but like it's a
daytime thing like say you're in
Manhattan and you're walking around you
know and you're doing some some cool
stuff all right wear it for that I could
wear it to the grocery store
I ordered my groceries though so oh okay
do you actually leave the apartment I'm
going to start after our conversation
today exactly I'm gonna be out and about
in London all the time tip number one
guys leave your apartment if you want to
find a partner yeah I'm gonna be out and
about I still don't think for a date if
you rock something there would that be
the right thing probably no I think
sometimes fashion for women is not
necessarily about men like it's you know
I wear that on a date probably not but
if I just want to look cool and funky at
brunch with my girlfriend yeah yeah yeah
I think I feel like I could take tack
your wrists in fashion if I'm just gonna
see my girls but if I'm trying to be you
know a sexy sensual fertile hot woman
it's not the move I don't like it when
girls are too
chubby let's say or like two it's it's
real it's a very cheap look do you know
what I mean you've got to get that
balance where it's quite classy as well
as being sexy you know right right I
know what you're talking about for those
of you that are confused about travs
okay it is I guess Britain's form of
Jersey Shore women that are just
ostentatious and tacky and it's not hot
commonly referred to as a hoochie mama
that is what that would be I picked the
shirt but this is the skirt we picked
out that's pretty nice okay okay I like
it but I think you have to wear that
orange one shoulder shirt I'll be back
okay yeah Rich Cooper
my scoop no no
for some reason no I mean he has like a
wolverine Vibe I guess I I'm telling it
my thing is five foot eight Lumberjacks
I love a bralucky ribbed guy that's just
my thing I don't like lean ripped men I
want you to look like you can chop wood
chop down a tree and also I think it's
just like the sexiest thing ever to
watch man chop wood too okay I switched
it yay yeah that's super cool that looks
really nice
what kind of where would I go with this
outfit I think you know I think that
could be an afternoon I think that could
be an evening outfit I think you could
go out in shortage wearing that you
could go to Canary Wharf to one of the
bars down there meet some nice high
value guy you know Eric is that where I
should go is that where you catch the
catch the Richmond Canary Wharf Canary
wolf yeah it's quite it's not far it's
one slap away yeah yeah you should get
down there this is quite cool bars there
you've got the guys who are working in
the banks that said it's over there
actually you see the buildings so yeah
definitely so what have we read this one
to ten
Eric is a high eight hi I feel like
a good thing it goes well
okay have you ever said oh this is
really crap program American program
called the Say Yes to the Dress I
haven't seen it of course I have you
know I'm a woman I stopped watching
cable TV a couple years ago so I think I
think that that's just I don't know part
of being a woman or a girl they're still
grown women that watch that stuff too
kind of shows an interest in women in
getting married I think well okay an
interest in having a wedding because I
think that's two very different things
but I think this is a lot like that I
feel like you should have a fashion show
I'm sorry like maybe maybe it doesn't
seem like the most masculine thing ever
but I beg to differ I beg to differ I
feel like you're just fly you know
something you guys just got it you know
what I mean thank you very much well I
think I've always been interested in
men's fashion like I've always been kind
of interested in stuff that makes you a
guy look good like I need to brush up in
terms of my skills in terms of analyzing
female clothing because there's a lot to
learn but I think I've got a sense of
what's stylish and what's classy or not
I bet I think that you're a good judge
of female fashion and you know I've
heard I've heard you're lucky with the
gals so I would imagine you've just seen
enough outfits on women or off women to
judge if an outfit is good or bad oh I
dated this girl at one time I met this
girl in uh
um in a in a coffee shop and she was
really really dressed down very pretty
face but really dressed down like baggy
jeans like hoodie and all this kind of
thing and I thought when she turns up on
the day she's gonna look great stand up
on the days wearing the same things
terrible
the new era
um so with this I think it's a game of
two halves I like the skirt the top I'm
not so sold on personally and
this was about outfit the pieces are
good that shirt is really good that
shirt might work with that last beige
skirt that you wore I think that's a
possibility that skirt can work but it's
it like you're tall is it the colors or
the the Fabrics it's both both because
you have a mix and texture and they have
a mixing color that's too sharp so what
color goes better with blue
black I I like blue the black shirt I
wore earlier with this
yeah you can try all right we'll try it
okay I'm a big Advocate fashion wise of
sheer tights because it can make the
shortest skirt ever look a touch more
wholesome you know do you think she'll
skirt it's as a rule the girl should
wear should wear tights I think possibly
on a date maybe that she should so not
look too overtly sexual if that makes
sense I think it depends on
your figure as a
little bit more in the back end so I
know that there's some Cuts Like The
pleated skirts yeah for me it's just
never gonna happen because it just puts
me too too provocative of a situation
but you know in terms of like pencil
skirts I think I have better luck with
that but if it's a little bit you know
higher than mid thigh it ends up just
looking more womanly if I wear it with
sheer tights well I think that looks
good but I think that looks more casual
now so I think that's more of a daytimey
kind of thing so this is what I'll go if
I go out in the day exactly exactly and
I and I'm trying to
we'll say you're just walking around or
you're like um you're going on errands
or maybe you're sitting in the cafe or
whatever but it doesn't look like an
evening
wear outfit to me yeah if I wanted to
make it evening what would I wear with
it a different top and sheer tights yeah
sheer tights and then we're kind of top
would it be you could I mean like a
button a black shirt would be good I'm
I'm good at Fashion contrary to popular
belief I just have a preference to to
just dress like I'm turning butter
it's just my thing you know uh I don't
think I've ever been that sexy of a
woman I know my I know my Lane I know my
Lane uh but if there is something
special going on with my husband you
know I'll be like hey you know how
should should I dress like sexy tonight
is it casual he's like okay go get sexy
and then I'll go ahead and do that um
yeah I think I just dig the whole
Midwest boots with a floral dress
situation I like that as well though
actually I like that as well like
daytime you see it's a whole different
ball game isn't it but I really like it
I really like floral dresses with girls
and I quite like when you say boots do
you mean like like cowboy boots or not
not a cowboy I'm not not at that but
like brown leather boots I like them
with certain dresses but I think that's
a very American thing I don't see anyone
in London in doing that but there's lots
of different things that you could wear
with a floral dress and you can you can
make it like homey or I guess like Hokey
or you can dress it up because if you
wear it with brown boots okay that's a
Midwest Vibe but if you wear it with
like a white strappy heel and that's a
cuter spring Vibe yeah yeah so I think
well at a minimum floral dresses seem to
be the answer for me oh
yeah
spin not too fast okay
yeah this is actually good very good I'm
done dressing like my mother on dates
mom your dress has gotta go that one
looked good though actually I think that
suited her hair color yeah yeah as a
brunette I'm like you know I can I can
work with it like light pink tends to
look really good on brunette hair kind
of thing outfit wise but there's just
some colors that are gonna look better
on her than they would on me like blue I
think would look better on her I think I
would do good with olive green and I
think she would too was getting the
Weeds about color and color is one of
those things if somebody's if this is
the thing you know if a guy comes to me
and says oh you know should I wear like
olive green or something like that I'm a
bit like you know probably best go to
see like uh somebody who's working at
like a store you know like somebody
who's like a personal shopper
um but I'm more interested like I can
I'm more interested in the overall look
like the cut of the clothes like the
silhouette oh right yeah see what I'm
saying I do know what you're saying um
I'm petite I have to get all my address
is tailored otherwise I look frumpy and
it's made a world of difference speaking
of Taylor I think I got this in the
wrong size I think it's too big oh
you'll get it fixed I kind of like I'm
fully in the back because it's too big
that is though a size aside that is
that's pretty cool but that is proper
like New Year's Eve party type yes
it's fitted
yeah
I feel like it's I feel like it's too
big though you see so yeah it's got to
be like yeah
but it is really nice now I have a
question because we're in something like
this I don't ever want to scream to a
guy like party girl you know what I mean
yeah and sometimes I think people talk
to me for five minutes so they're like
maybe maybe they wanted to fight you
know what I mean like that's always I
think as a girl the scare that what like
why I get nervous to wear stuff like
this well cause he's gonna pigeonhole
you in them yeah yeah what do you think
what do you think well I think
I think for a date that would be too
much okay really I think if you were
genuine on a night out you know say you
you took some of the guys out and you're
like yeah let's go to a party and
whatever that would be fine but I think
for a date too much
um I think it depends on the context
then really but some of the stuff that
you wore earlier like maybe even the
last dress you know like for a day that
could work pretty well or one of the
things with the skirt so yeah but I mean
if a girl turned up and she was wearing
that I wouldn't I wouldn't be judgmental
about it I'd be like yeah cool whatever
you know she's rocking it but yeah I I
feel like the older I got the more I
realized guys don't really think about
that that much like I don't yeah does
she look like oh they're just like oh
she looks hot yeah yeah exactly exactly
well what was your favorite outfit I
think maybe the dress before just before
last uh-huh or what was the one before
that we gave to it we gave an eight oh
are you talking about the the burnt
orange with the cream shirt I mean uh
the burnt orange shirt with the cream
skirt yes that one yeah those are the
top two yeah I like the last one I think
I like that one I'll probably wear it
for the show tonight I think that it was
a really positive experience I just
think that Pearl's platform is too big
to dress like a 10 000 subscriber
Channel any longer it needs to be over
it needs to be done Jennifer your
dresses are getting returned to you I
know you didn't want her to take them
anyway I'm sure this wasn't consensual
at all and yeah I look forward to the
new thumbnails a new branding shoot I
feel like she's gonna be Super Fly and
rope in a guy I think it's really
exciting because some of those Loops
that she showcased just now super cool
you know it's definitely like definitely
turning up the volume definitely turning
up the heat and I think that's what we
need to do like all of us men and women
we need to think about how we're
presenting ourselves so important
because like you know it's apart from
your you know your height maybe your
your build or whatever whatever they see
when you're walking into the bar this is
the the main thing people are going to
notice is how you dress how you present
yourself so it's it's super super key I
think for men and for women and um it
was really cool just to see the
transformation straight yeah and I think
that women if you're intimidated when it
comes modern dating just keep in mind
99.9 of women out there are super frumpy
so just put on a dress just try just all
you need to do to be honest if you put
on a direct so that puts you ahead of
like 97 of the competition really yeah
yeah highly recommend but thank you for
coming and doing this video idea I feel
like it was so much fun and yes it's
because I think that he's the best
dressed in the manosphere so there you
go thank you very much Ellie yeah
pleasure thank you for this episode
episode one of wife school um we're
starting it early um shout out to Trey
if you guys want if the women's want
advice if the men want advice go to Troy
first yeah check out my check out my
YouTube channel at real Troy Francis
okay guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification Bell and we'll talk to you
next time